you know who's got a big house Hassan I
was just about to say yeah yeah if we're
talking about the most expensive houses
bro like obviously what I'm right here
you know who has the most expensive
house the most no one is at a house like
this before Hassan [ __ ] dude big garage
for your Porsche too yeah yeah you gonna
get a second car
no
Just Gonna Keep it to the one do you
like that car yeah I love it actually
it's like it was weird but I got used to
it like at first it was like it was like
an RC car you know what I mean usually
like you just press you just hit the
[ __ ] gas pedal it's ironic that you
say that because you picked this up
and you looked at it first of all it was
it I like how when you interact with
things here you look like a giant like
you came
into like our little hobbit home and
you're literally holding it with two
fingers and you're like what is this
yeah I mean but like is this for an RC
car oh okay
I just yeah yeah I'm just laughing
because the size of that car is what
your car looks like to you yeah it is
it's the only Porsche I can fit into
other than like the real the dentist
line you know what I mean like the
panameras and all the other ones yeah so
I was like how tall are you I'm just 6'4
I'm not that tall
only like six eight eight no I mean I
mean that would be tall I think six four
is like
that's short
price and price you can move it towards
you let's not let's not get into that
yeah
what a door yeah what is short yeah um
okay well I I think short is uh is a
mindset that's what I think okay that's
what it is number six what you're saying
no no I I don't know like [ __ ] dude I
never even think about it like so I
don't know
you have had sex with so many girls
you're just saying what they say I don't
even no I mean I don't yeah yeah I don't
know no you're the perfect size yeah no
I like your size the big ones scare me
okay to be fair like I uh I just have
had sex with a lot of women no that's
not to be fair I have had a lot of sex a
lot of countries girls yeah that was not
what I was saying okay um you said how
are you gonna how are we gonna rip me
while he's right here hey this
conversation's about you he's literally
conversation is about you because we
have we talked pretty boy over here
dogging people we've dogged him out for
many many episodes oh okay and he's just
conversations about you we're here to
address the problem you're [ __ ] way
too many girls that's not true but
that's not even true that's not even
true anymore like I just [ __ ] anymore
I'm 31 man I'm you know I've lived a lot
I've lived a whole ass life more than
you you know listen
listen listen all I'm saying is yeah I
was 23 once yeah okay yeah and uh you
know but I I stream too much I'm on
[ __ ] time for any of that [ __ ] damn
yeah damn dude I'm live eight to ten
hours oh I know does that not make you
go insane like are you totally is I
think I wouldn't change it all no I was
already insane so it's like perfect for
me really yeah you still enjoy it yeah I
love it everything I'm like uh you know
sometimes it gets sometimes you get
burnt out
um especially when you're like beefing
with someone with like a larger
Community or a large community as well
and you know there's like if there's
like big drama or some [ __ ] like
like it starts wearing on you a little
bit
um but uh ultimately it's just you know
I take a day off I chill out and then I
come back because I do I legitimately
love it imagine taking a day off [ __ ]
old people [ __ ] honestly yeah I mean I I
I do seven days a week usually do a
vacation not really no what do you love
it that much yeah I I
the moment I'm not enjoying it I would
just stop you're doing 70 hours a week
I'm 70. uh more than that sometimes
that's child's place
I'm watching you guys interact because
it's too hot people just kind of
posturing at each other and it's so
funny and different Generations too yeah
so for the entirety like when when covet
happened
um in 2020 the entire year I streamed 42
of the whole year like 42 the entire
year I was on camera yeah and then um I
think like is that an autistic fact yeah
yeah like 100 how many hours in a year
no because there's a I don't [ __ ]
know what's that site or or is it just
shut up this tracker yeah twitch tracker
go to Twitch tracker it it shows how
many days I've lowered it now you're
like you're live how much money did you
make
um you can find that out on the internet
as a matter of fact people oh yeah
because twitch whatever yeah yeah
someone twitch guy forgot about that all
right yeah like I actually Google that
yeah
um and and unlike many of my peers I'm
one of the only people that like I I
don't really give a [ __ ] because I
openly show my sub count anyway like you
can just like literally calculate it in
your mind if you want to figure it out
can we go to the little um the little
like lottery ticket layout where where
it has little square punches
how do you get to that [ __ ] is that is
that the bottom I don't even know but
basically wait go up
8771 hours
yeah
you know what would be really funny is
if price will check how much do you make
and then Hassan said it and then the
price goes wow you streamed all year for
that yeah I'm just doing a movie yeah I
was about to say like I was about to say
like I I try movies no I made I made a
lot like I made it a lot of money for in
comparison to the average human being
which you know I was uh not that [ __ ]
long ago you know what I mean just
talking about that yeah this is not the
first time that we've done a podcast
again no where is the old episode we'll
unearth that [ __ ] dude I took it down
because I was like I look like I watched
it back I was like I look like an idiot
like you look so smart and I'm just
sitting there the whole time being like
how many years ago was it seven
something like that it was crazy yeah
he's crazy like I we met so long ago we
met like 10 11 years ago you were
literally a baby bro like when we
[ __ ] met he was like 13 12. yeah he
was like he was like coming off vine
he's like I don't know what the [ __ ] I'm
gonna do with my career like still
working at full screen I think right
both of you guys yeah and I remember we
did like this thing it was like you me
Jimmy Tatro and like a couple other
people which is wild because like a lot
of people on that table popped off I
know right yeah that was a successful
ass table seven years ago yeah or ten
years ago however many years prices like
you guys were popping yeah yeah yeah
yeah I don't see you around dude I I
grew up watching you guys he's like it's
just crazy not me though but I don't
really watch Twitch nah don't worry I
was not on Twitch before but I was
always doing politics so when you did
politics
I'm a I'm a political commentator wait
maybe cut that I didn't know that no no
no no no no that's hilarious that's so
that's funny as [ __ ] one of the funniest
things to happen
um well you know hey speaking of twitch
it feels I feel like a [ __ ] for that
I don't know I feel like that we can
make this feel a little bit more at home
for Hassan okay
um well your Hassan is so used to
Fielding random chatter and random
people just interrupting his trains of
thought
so I figured we would oh no emulate that
so Chad come on in here
yeah just wherever you like yeah you
just post up over there how many people
did you bring into the [ __ ] spaceship
dude I mean we had to make it a w in the
chat real this is crazy oh wow you know
just general oh you think this is my
audience demographic
I mean you never know they don't really
know who's behind the user what it could
be what is your I feel Barbara is
looking right at me right now yeah can
we get a can we get a w in the chat
w
laughs
nice
this is this is madness what you've done
here is it yeah
yeah
yeah
can I ban them
yeah
three heads
all right yeah now just continuous huh
all right well I'm not gonna thank him
because I never would what were you
saying about the yeah what were you
saying about the political commentator
anyway yeah I'm a political commentator
I've been doing it for a very long time
L uh yeah was that you no what that was
no that was the chat keep going just
keep going keep going great keep going
no just keep going you're fine I can't
oh my God what bro you're saying it no
I'm not that was them okay yeah just
continue anyway I've been doing it
oh who's it it's a lot different when
it's in person isn't it it is a lot
different I got I got I can't stop
immediately continue continue sorry
what's going on
um but yeah I've been doing it for for a
long time
and and
now I do it on Twitch I used to do it on
The Young Turks which I'm sure you're
not familiar wait what did you think I
did
you thought it was a gamer yeah you were
trying you said you were trained on them
you said you were trending on uh Twitter
all the time
there'd be [ __ ] in here being
like ah actually you're like a bad
person because you bought a house
actually you're a bad you're a bad
person and then I would [ __ ] click on
I would click on you bring you to the
[ __ ] town square and execute you
as all the other Chatters doing manga
W's hi
all right all right Chad you for now
thank you so much thank you guys so much
thank you guys thanks for watching
have a great day they'll be back later
don't worry oh Jesus Christ I just give
to them all so oh yeah